hello everybody my name is marketed sad
I'll go with it
hi everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to let's play live a little
above of us that game that you wanted me
played again because I screwed it up
last time but here we go ray it's not
that hard what that music is on my ears
Oh lame jokes to start I am I really
gonna start it off like this
the worst joke I could possibly think of
and then yeah there's how it's gonna go
this is how this is gonna be the intro
that I did and the oh my oh I forgot how
to play isn't that delightful ha oh
goodness this is this is a fantastic
start I sincerely forgot to Blair
alright alright who you you're doing
wait a minute where am i no this is
wrong ha ha ha how do I get down there I
was supposed to be able to go there oh I
fall in the pit over there and then I'm
able to make it oh okay hang on
everybody
jump oops my bad foot hip ah it can't be
this bad this early or can I can I reach
new levels of bad ice sure can
with your powers combined I am captain
suck ass ah alright this is this is off
to the worst start I could have possibly
imagined in any game that I've oh really
this is how what it's gonna be like in
any game that I've ever played
have I ever started it off this horribly
the answer is maybe probably knowing my
track record the answers definitely
really oh really oh really dear friend
is that is that what we're doing in
glorious motherland home country of
cabin river like what is wrong what is
wrong with me just do it
I'm not faking anything I'm not oh god
damn it
that took far too long congratulations I
am awful at life find whatever oh really
this is the wrong place isn't it I'm not
gonna be able to get through there am I
am I Emma wait no I probably yeah Wow
you know what's good screw it I'm not
gonna deal with it I'm not gonna do that
I'm not gonna do the thing that I just
wasted five minutes getting to and I'm
not gonna I mean you can't make me I'm
not gonna do it I'm oh I'm gonna fall
into the pit as many times as I can
because this is entertaining for the
youtubes
fine I'll go there what do I care
going up screw you guys I'm going up
this is long stop being funny so why not
got dingus another hump mother of dum
eleventeen gajillion dum screw this and
everything you care about oh well I
might want to get to the other side of
the map there's a will you know that
look at our empty space under the yellow
how am I supposed to be able to go over
there if you're not gonna let me never
like you know what oh really no no oh
there was a save option really
that would have been delightful to know
about when I was in agony when I last
played this all right you know what
we're gonna do a do-over we're gonna do
a door we're doing others we're doing
this offer everybody we're doing this
over hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to let's play
event of the lava lava my favorite game
oh look it's so magical in every way I
can't wait to play I've been eagerly
anticipating my return to this game
because there is none that I love more
then this game in all of its intricate
gaming mechanics animes oh this is how I
I mean they all look where I found
myself on the other side
man Wow gee willikers I knew that I
could do it if only I believed in the
power of love which I don't but it's
okay I'm not gonna hold that against me
where does this go I don't know I'm just
I just know that I am filled with such
happiness and love despite our best
efforts the Ananda dimensional
stabilizer won't hold out forever its
collapse is inevitable ah these
coordinates aren't even in this
dimension how do you know that how do
you know that little guy
you see able to read it me like me doc
dimensionally accurate huh I didn't saw
your intelligence little guy but I mean
come on it's a bit of a reach don't you
think yeah whatever you just do what you
want to do I trust you implicitly now if
only I can figure out where the hell I'm
going I would love to be a whoo well
well well outer hull truth what does
that mean oh oh oh I see I'm just along
for a ride now am i I don't even get to
choose anymore I don't get to choose to
die oh wait what Sarah I saw oh so sad
no oh how many do that ah there we go
ha ha ha I found a shiny trinket where
am I going now oh oh oh no this bass
backwards this bass backwards will get
you all right so Oh Oh true Oh
I don't need your oh I need your I don't
eat how I need your stupid ass I don't I
don't need your help
I don't need your I don't need your
stupid ass truth yeah
I'm the greatest there ever was go this
way cuz it's easier oh it wasn't easier
hello little dancing skeletons is it
Cinco DeMayo no not sing Queen that the
Day of the Dead which one's the Day of
the Dead tablet schoo el so gently
ha I need it oh I do
Oh haha got you whoops I was a mistake
well gee willikers what am I supposed to
do
Oh dah alright oh come on yeah yeah yeah
all those two bastards too fast too fast
gotta go gotta go with the flow of it
yeah tuned too late too late too late
gotta go further than that oh not too
soon
ah too much yeah oh so close
forgot that one god I just I had a
stroke there and I didn't do it right
yeah nope no I didn't do it
looking at a pretty bird soft pair of
boobs and got distracted this generally
I just did yeah dogs there goes there
goes alone
i I just slipped it slipped I slipped do
zoo in Florida yeah there we go
yay graves oh I see it oh no it's a Tim
Tom tiny thing you ain't it oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah
who is the best not me obviously this is
hard I can already tell Oh am I just
going for a shiny trinket why do I want
this son of a [ __ ] why do I want this
the answer is I do not I don't I'm going
for it anyway because I gotta kill time
oh they aren't just I thought they were
dissing degradable one oh well this
makes it much easier disintegrate Abel
yeah yeah look at me go I'm like a
champion of life in all of its pleasures
maybe not all of its pleasures but
something mahan how do i well not like
that I gotta go get the shiny it was
over there
oh I get it oh I I do have to go forward
oh I get it
and then I get to come back the shiny is
over there no I want to go see the lies
I hated that exhibit at the Museum there
yeah I could make a joke but I won't
everyone ponder what joke I was not
gonna make hahaha who was I gonna offend
that's it that's a real answer you have
to ask yourself who was margov liar
gonna offend OOP ah gotcha [ __ ] yeah
yeah it would have sucked if I messed it
up there but I did not wait nope
this is ass backwards Philippi Luke no
daddies we're or aroni wrong dad
rice-a-roni wrong grammar ah
oh no that absolutely the work you
couldn't possibly be any badder whoa
ha ha ha ah all that effort for a
stupid-ass shiny trinket that I did not
need why did I do that
ha ha hey the answer is I can't answer
myself
it's sad stay to my mind
hey but it's a shiny it's shiny it's a
shiny trinket it's so pretty
he did I'm doing this how am i doing all
know what I was thinking backwards old
I'm I'm like completely wrong you need
it oh my god I can't believe that was
that was awful of me
those horrifyingly bad way no how am I
supposed to be able to go there wasn't
enough bloom no no no it can't be it
can't be true that's not true that's
impossible
does it show like at the end of this
game the statistics of how many deaths
I've had oh come on okay I thought it
was impossible for a second there I had
a sneaking suspicion then who was not
going to let me go
killed by lies isn't that a sad state of
who our lives aren't we all being killed
slowly by lies lies from our parents who
won't let us buy that new album that we
like we'll get bigger gauges in our ears
why mobiles 16 Bob the blind to me the
double using the system to push me down
what am I talking about
I don't know I'm playing a game loosen
that I can't go that way ah man just
like lies from from the government all
filled with lies what are the tones the
truth about 9/11 who rely fly man
nothing like a good old 911 joke to
finish it all off damn this isn't
another commentary on the pollution from
the big business corporation who
produced radish shucks the money but in
the system there's stealin run a little
bball to kill it in their own blankets
damn these people damn car races damn at
all oh damn ah very angry where ya from
a teleporter
why good God
oh no I'm just going back into the way I
came
well I was gonna have to kill myself
eventually why not be after this game
let's just go for it you know oh boy oh
we know that's I've already gotten to
him never mind
ah ah ah ha ha
I already fear oh really is that how
it's gonna be
well I'll just go around I really okay
excuse me that was very rude of me
what am i doing firming oh this looks
nice
where does this lead to my imminent
demise I've been finding a lot of that
recently uh this is a game that you
don't get good at Oh
iced tea labelled boo yeah now just to
escape the lies from the corporation I
know yeah the corporations when are they
gonna stop lying to us man
oh one lies beneath our spikes ha ha ha
ha ha
find it winder find out where these lies
go oh wait I already know the American
public who hath lent lied to all over
the bat is the TV does nothing from the
TV comes but lies I need to stop that
some people are gonna think I'm actually
being serious I mean I'm not gonna get
into political commentary here that's
for damn sure
it's one thing I'm definitely going to
avoid this comment this this this this
YouTube channel is meant for
entertainment purposes only
huh oh no I did this died yeah besides I
don't think anyone that makes constant
butt jokes is qualified to talk about
politics pretty sure pretty sure yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah the aw come on I'm just
trying to live just pick yourself down
I'm gonna pick yourself up into into
death here no oh good thing that was a
thing there I was wearing for all know
that was the wrong choice that was the
opposite of what I wanted to do that's a
lot of a checker points why so many
uncheck appoints oh ah ah guy in there
seriously man ain't worth it there we go
no never never never never never never
never do ya know ya know where's this
how about I bet here oh my god oh no oh
no oh no oh no
ah
humbugs blue hair ski oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah I don't know where I'm going but I
like it oh oh you tricked me
you tricked me oh no you didn't I needed
to do that in order to unleash the power
of this II wonder if the generator we
set up in the polar dimension is
affecting our teleporters no it's
probably just a glitch maybe he's a god
that michael fassbender Michael fast but
how oh I get it you're supposed to
unlock it and then go well you can't get
me to bow why was it a deception
what was you septum about it yeah
yep yep oh you ain't going to kill me
now but how in the balls did all I know
swap no this skill it is to match cannot
handle this much I don't wanna hear a
word audience
ah the skill it is too much they cannot
handle all of my win oh I feel so good
ah I do not know I did not feel good I
do not feel good
hmm what a strange dimension this is hey
yeah you got the jib dude Turin good to
see you all right professor ship yo is
badly damaged but violets been working
on fixing it we could really use your
help
really ah of course
the background interference in this
dimension prevented the ship from
finding a teleporter when we grabbed
we've all been teleported to different
locations
oh that sounds about right let's get
back to the ship in after you captain
okay oh good at least this is one that's
right here this is the one where it was
actually hard to get to you how many is
left no no I didn't think I want to
finish the game I have rescued a crew
member one remains I don't want to find
him I don't want to find oh not again no
Villa Larry who are you who's those
little er captain no hang on I'll save
you will I save him whoa what the
whoa what uh whoa don't mess with my
brain started out up shut up
what what I know what's babies into what
happened what the hell happened
what
oh god no oh god what is this super
hexagon again oh god I'm out of time I
get out of it get out of it get out of
here we go that's what I call winning in
my book hide sickles five sickles at
least say allow me hahahaha oh god I'm
gonna die I'm gonna die and not from
this game I'm gonna kill myself by
pointing a cannon full of AIDS and
shooting at my face oh hey it's
something every five seconds
cuz it knows this is unfair who and who
who who could do this we need Kat and
super reflexes to do this otherwise
known as Superman floods nutters but at
least I made it to another one oh my
goodness gravy boats a house slick moves
Kenton Wow look at me go oh don't look
at me don't look at me
I'm ashamed don't look at me I wanted to
quit and yet here I am playing the game
still still all really owes this oh oh
oh I'm sorry did I interrupt your day
with my needing to record for my fans
did I did I did I did I did I run over
your dog or something on the way huh
your little dog is gonna get it next
time
on gamegrumps hi good God
who would do this for fun who would fund
this who would this fun who have any
funds
am I having shut up trying to
concentrate I did better when I all
really I had that five seconds you just
didn't give it I know what the last ten
seconds are gonna be oh good golly Miss
Molly oh come on I just want this five
seconds good go
Gallagher look I give it a five
I'm a goofy goober yeah you're a goofy
goober yeah we're all goofy goobers yeah
doofy gimme gimme gimme gimme
oh I thought I was gonna make it
I fine I had a sneaking Sisseton I des e
nah dude II wonder what's over here
loop yeah nothing going G hope done and
done done no more no more I don't want
no more you'll suck ten dicks and go see
a doctor is that who many probably
Lethal lethal dose of dick I think it's
Mel coincidence that the teleporter was
drawn to that dimension there's
something there I think it might be
causing the interference that's stopping
us from leaving really really what
that's doing today
you know al does everything the outro
I'm